[Musique]
le curieux ont dit qu'ils collectionnent
les histoires étranges et dès lors qu'on
entend siffler on sent que quelque chose
d'effrayant est sur le point de se
passer et si je te disais que je peux te
donner le pouvoir de contrôler tes
parents tu vas voir
et si personne hors jeu tra ce que le
monde considère comme une anomalie le
considérons comme un don du ciel
ce n'est pas de la triche c'est une
victoire sans obstacle
en effet si tu cherches quelque chose
moment il se passe un truc tellement
bizarre réfléchit bien éloigne toi tout
de suite de ce pub on sait jamais qui
pourraient devoir moment et n'a pas fait
rire c'est ça tu cherches au rang des
conséquences recommence et tu devra en
payer le prix
j'ai l'impression qu'il a décidé de
venger ceux à qui tu as fait du mal
[Musique]
oui mais tu apprends
tu commences à regretter la décision
c'est ça
[Rires]